since first appearing on screen in
2018's black panther the african nation
of wakanda has become one of the most
iconic settings in the mcu
but what's the real story behind
t'challa's homeland this is the history
of wakanda
explained everyone knows wakanda as the
civilization that discovered vibrania
the true origins of the country however
are far more complicated than that
and are rooted in a deep and mysterious
mysticism
wakanda was originally home to a
collection of beasts known as the
originators
among these ancient creatures were
beings such as the serpentine symbi
the ape-like vanion the arachnoid anansi
and the insectoid swarm
known as the creeping doom eventually
ancient human beings were drawn to the
area where they soon encountered these
strange beasts
they all lived in harmony for a while
but the originators balked when humans
started to abuse the land's natural
resources
a deadly conflict ensued and among the
human combatants arose heroes that
ascended to become the gods of wakanda
otherwise known as the urisha with the
help of the urisha
the originators were defeated and
banished to the nether realms forever
losing the land they had called home
wakanda was founded shortly after for
years the country developed pretty much
just like any other ancient civilization
but soon enough thanks to a little
cosmic mischief a rock from outer space
would land in wakanda
one that would forever change the marvel
universe
in the early days of wakanda the
country's ancient denizens learned to
manipulate storm clouds
in order to funnel cosmic energy for
their own ends
but this practice had an unintended side
effect it caused the wakandans to pull
down a meteor from space
this meteor contained a metal that
absorbed both sound and energy
which the world would later come to call
vibranium
the first tribe to be brave enough to
investigate the meteor crash site was
led by bashanga
wakanda's biggest and baddest warrior
bushenga immediately saw the value of
this new substance and decided to put it
to use in his tribe's weapons giving
them an edge over their foes
nowadays vibranium is one of the most
important aspects of the marvel universe
for one thing it's what captain
america's shield is constructed from the
most versatile substance on the planet
and they used it to make a frisbee but
the use of this metal helped modern
wakanda become the beacon of
technological advancement that it is
today
not to mention the most well-defended
country on the planet
while the benefits of vibranium are
clear its discovery set off a chain of
events that would forever change the
landscape of the world
it also ushered in a series of
unintended and deadly consequences
although bashanga's brutal methods may
have seemed suited towards a simpler
more primitive time he ended up being
one of the most important figures in
wakandan history
bushenga first believed the vibranium
meteor to be a gift from the gods
unfortunately his tribe quickly found
that exposure to untreated vibranium can
mutate living things on earth
into grotesque monsters which they named
demon spirits
in order to combat these new foes
bashanga prayed to the panther god to
give him the strength to defeat them
thus making him the first of the proper
black panthers
basically if you were born in ancient
wakanda and ended up being exposed to a
little too much vibranium there was a
good chance you'd turn into a monster
and a super powered panther would show
up and beat the living hell out of you
now it was later revealed that there had
actually been a prehistoric black
panther
but the lineage that ends with king
t'challa got its start with bashanga's
battles against the demon spirits
eventually bashanga united the region's
various tribes
and formed the singular nation of
wakanda
the radiation from the vibranium meteor
didn't just affect people though
it also had an impact on the flora and
fauna of the surrounding area
hence the special herbs that black
panthers consumed to give them their
powers
after becoming the first black panther
bashango recognized the destructive
power of the vibranium meteor
and closed it off to the rest of the
kingdom in the process
he also established the black panther
cult who swore to use the powers of the
meteor to protect the people of wakanda
and stop the demon spirits from
spreading but while wakanda's black
panther cult is obviously the most
prominent
it's not the only one and the wakandans
worship a number of other animal gods
these groups include the lion cult the
crocodile cult the hyena clan
and the most dangerous of all the white
gorilla cult
t'challa's rival imbaku who is otherwise
known as man abe
would lead the people of his village in
consuming the flesh of the mutated white
gorillas of the region
gaining their super strength for
themselves mbaku would eventually use
this power to overthrow the black
panther
and briefly take the throne of wakanda
for himself if the world found out what
we truly are what we possess
we could lose our way of life throughout
history
many have tried to invade wakanda and
many have failed too
all kinds of armies ranging from the
romans to the knights templar
to hordes of demons from hell have made
their way to the region
and were each thoroughly beaten back
however
in the 1800s the country faced its
greatest threat yet
led by the belgian colonel named claw a
group of white soldiers targeted the
area after an otherwise successful
conquest of south africa
luckily they were no match for the
wakandan technology which caused their
guns to misfire
colonel claw himself was killed during
the invasion but that wasn't the last
wakanda had seen of the claw family
unfortunately for the wakandans claw had
an equally deplorable sun
and when world war ii came around
colonel fritz claw couldn't join the
nazis fast enough
he made his way to wakanda in an attempt
to impress hitler
only to be welcomed by the then current
black panther king azuri
and shown the secrets of its vibranium
then when his real intentions became
clear
claude jr was beaten back to germany but
this event put wakanda firmly in the
crosshairs of both the axes and allies
that's when azuri and his son t'chaka
enlisted the help of captain america to
keep the nazis led by baron strucker and
the red skull from taking over the
country
the battle against the nazis was the
first modern invasion that wakanda had
fought
and against a technologically advanced
and highly knowledgeable enemy no less
it was this war that taught a young
t'chaka of the dangers of the outside
world
and how desperately they coveted
wakanda's secrets
many stories that involved the black
panther tend to pick up during the reign
of t'chaka
largely because he was perhaps the most
important ruler the country had seen up
to that point
certainly king t'chaka was a significant
influence on the country's decision to
keep itself cut off from the world
raised in the turbulent times of world
war ii t'chaka saw what happens when the
outside world discovers wakanda for what
it truly is and how it almost
always ends with the spilling of
wakandan blood his solution was to
conceal wakanda from the outside world
tricking everyone into thinking it had
no more to offer than any other african
country
t'chaka would sell a little vibranium
technology here and there
in order to keep the lights on while at
the same time secretly developing the
country's sharpest minds
to this end t'chaka developed a system
in which wakanda would send its best
and brightest to study abroad so that
they could bring their knowledge back to
wakanda
and help it thrive in secrecy
unfortunately things fell apart when
ulysses s
claw a descendant of the belgian colonel
led an assassination mission into
wakanda
during claws attack t'chaka was killed
protecting his young son t'challa
in return t'challa avenged his father by
shattering claw's right arm
in the comics when t'chaka died t'challa
was just 13 years old
far too young to take the throne as per
wakandan customs his uncle sian
performed the ritual
and became the next black panther acting
as king region in his nephew's stead
while sayon kept things in check
t'challa went to study in europe and the
united states
he would eventually gain a phd in
physics from oxford university
before finally coming of age and
returning to wakanda to take his
rightful place on the throne
t'challa's homecoming was briefly
waylaid by the organization known as aim
who captured him while he was looking
for the heart-shaped herb that would
give him the power of the black panther
luckily he managed to escape with the
help of a childhood friend and went on
to beat his uncle in the infamous
wakandan combat ritual
once all was said and done t'challa had
gained the superhuman powers of the
black panther
as well as the heavy responsibility of
ruling his secret kingdom
many of the early black panther stories
involved t'challa grappling with his
loyalty to his father's legacy as
wakanda grows and prospers
having developed new kinds of technology
and welcomed a number of new superheroes
the country eventually became
impossible to hide under king t'challa
wakanda finally revealed itself to the
world
we must find a way to look after one
another
as if we were one single
tribe one of the most infamous events in
marvel history is the secret invasion
which saw an alien race known as the
skrulls attempt to invade earth by
posing as the planet's key leaders and
heroes
inevitably the skrulls quickly
identified wakanda's importance
and wasted no time in infiltrating the
country fortunately black panther got
wise to their ruse and took steps to
ensure that he could pull a fast one on
the invaders
eventually things came to a head and the
scroll invasion of wakanda was reduced
to a good old-fashioned battle
in the end the wakandan army won out and
sent a ship full of scroll corpses back
to their home planet
with words of warning written in blood
on the walls
this war against the scrolls taught
t'challa that wakanda's advanced tech
wouldn't be enough to save it as the
universe grew bigger
and he was right now knowing that he
desperately needed new allies
t'challa found his chance to open
wakanda's borders when the avengers
engaged in an all-out war with the x-men
this war soon made its way to wakanda
when namor the king of atlantis
managed to unleash a devastating tsunami
on the country while possessed by the
galactic power of the dark phoenix
the destruction was widespread and
t'challa was filled with rage
he vowed revenge on neymar and became
absolutely consumed with his quest for
vengeance
despite being outmatched by the dark
phoenix t'challa and his friends managed
to stop neymar while there was still
some semblance of wakanda to salvage
t'challa's sister shuri led the
reconstruction of wakanda
but the wakandans never forgot or
forgave namor and his atlanteans
a war broke out between the two nations
but partly because wakanda was still
weak
a somewhat contrite neymar offered the
country generous peace terms
shuri rejected the terms however and led
a successful campaign to invade and
destroy atlantis
later when thanos came to earth neymar
tricked him into attacking wakanda
allowing the mad titan and his black
order to take part of the country
for the first time ever under a black
panther king wakanda had lost a portion
of its precious land
following these numerous tragedies
social and political upheaval began to
take shape
as people lost faith in king t'challa
and his court
two revolutionary factions emerged the
midnight angels and the people
an offshoot of the dora milaje the
midnight angels began practicing
vigilante justice in the face of a
government and king that seemingly
couldn't get the job done
the people were more like religious
zealots who carried out terrorist
attacks designed to further destabilize
the wakandan government
meanwhile the black panther fought to
ensure the survival of the legacy of his
ancestors
and keep his subjects safe at any cost
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic heroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one